écoutez moi j'ai quelque chose à vous
dire je ne veux pas savoir qui a eu
l'idée de me faire cette merveilleuse
surprise
je ne veux pas savoir combien de temps
vous allez rester près de moi mais je
vais vous sachiez une chose c'est qu'ici
vous êtes chez vous et qu'aujourd'hui
moi je suis l'homme le plus heureux du
monde et toutes les bonnes choses ont
une fin
j'ai une très mauvaise nouvelle à vous
annoncer un pas une pierre un chemin qui
fournit un reste de racine
c'est un peu solitaire c'est un éclat de
verre
c'est la vie au soleil
c'est la mort le sommeil c'est un piège
entre ouvert un arbre millénaire
c'est un chien qui aboie certaines
manger dans l'air c'est un cran qui pour
elle la mère et qui font le mystère au
profond la prom a souri
si le souffle du vent au sommet des
collines
c'est une vieille mine le vider
non c'est la pluie qui jacassent c'est
là vers ce qu'ils versent des torrents
d'allégresse ce sont les hauts de mars
c'est le pied qui avance